[Music]
I literally dropped a bomb on them Dance
Moms star Abby Lee Miller is out and
former Dancing with the Stars Pro Cheryl
Burke is in et has exclusively learned
the former Dancing with the Stars Pro
will be stepping in for the remainder of
the season there are only four episodes
left to be filmed this comes after the
50 year old reality star announced she
quit the show in a heated post on
Instagram Monday night writing in part I
will no longer take part in Dance Moms I
don't have a problem working with any
kid I just have a problem with being
manipulated disrespected and used day in
and day out by men who never took a
dance lesson in their lives and treat
women like dirt I have been doing all
the costume design making the costumes
running downtown buying the costumes
getting the parking tickets for seven
seasons now and I'm like my account said
this is ridiculous you're losing money
you're wasting your time I'm not getting
paid for more on Abby Lee's Dance Moms
departure tune in to ET for an exclusive
sit-down interview Wednesday March 29th
you
you